Carroll 11 to 14 he has 24 for Top Chef
this way to rent
[Applause]
baby has been doing everything tonight
from all areas of the floor how does he
even get to the basket on that angle and
Lou Williams I'm trying to tell you one
of the best at luring you into reaching
as soon as you reach
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
kaydee again how does he find this angle
I don't know move out the way get dumped
though a little Williams so smooth on
the other hand this is why the ball
needs to be in his hands
[Applause]
[Music]
Williams
[Applause]
Monica didn't charge between
[Applause]
[Music]
and the truckers get to it off the
turnover
Williams puts it up off the land at
school minute and a half remaining
Williams walked out and hits again
and we bought it
five Beverly 35 seconds to go calamari
cuts it down everybody
by privily 35 seconds to go gotta Larry
cuts it down
rebounds that is incredible the leading
rebounder for both teams tonight in LA
on Friday night while the Houston
Rockets could rest after their victory
over the Utah welcome back to Golden
State the first two games who Williams
averaged 30 points the last two games 14
well now he's coming back imagine missed
the pitch of the war is he in outscored
59 - 17 s + 42 he knows it that's why
he's over there hugging his voice and we
almost got it too much time a lot of
time left though the Warriors can get
right back in this but now the blue
Willie's has any